CORS has been
adopted by API providers
as the primary way
to share resources.
CORS Headers permit
cross origin requests
without relying on
JavaScript, though they
do need some server side code.
CORS Headers allows
servers to specify
a set of origins
that are allowed
to access its resources.
If the request referrer
header is on that list,
It will be able to inspect
the answer and use the data,
problem solved.
However, if you
take a closer look,
you will realize
that by the time
the server sends
back the headers,
the request will
already have executed.
This can become problematic
with [INAUDIBLE] operations.
Because it is already too
late to ignore the request.
This is where preflight
requests come into play.
A preflight request
uses the options method
and allows the browser
to signal that it only
wants to check what is
allowed and what is not.
The server should not execute
any kind of business logic,
but only return the headers,
similar to a head request.
However, not all requests
will be preflighted.
Requests that are made
because of image tags or forms
will not be preflighted.
So any kind of get request
will be sent straight away.
You just won't be able
to read the answer
if CORS doesn't allow it.
The details about when
preflight requests are actually
sent with CORS are
intricate and extensive.
So I'll leave a link with
details in the instructor
notes.
Now, we have a couple of ways
to get around the single origin
restriction.
If you're ever involved in
publishing an API yourself,
I'd encourage you to think about
CORS from the very beginning
and to enable it on your server.